في الصين انه يحث على الالتزام بمبدا صين
واحده والتعامل بعنايه مع القضايا
المتعلقه بالتايوان ووصف المكتب والحزب
واكتب الحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي التايواني
بالمتامر مع قوه خارجيه للمطالبه
بالاستقلال حسب قوله كما قال ان زعيمه
تايوان
انحاز تماما مع الولايات المتحده
وقالت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان السلطات
الحزب الديمقراطيه الحاكم في تايوان
مستعده لتحويل الجزيره الى برميل بارود
واضاف المتحدث باسم الوزاره ان بلاده تذكر
بعض الدول بانه ليس بامكان القوات
الاجنبيه حمايتها بل انها تفاقم التوتر
وتجلب الكوارث لنفسها هذا واكد المتحدث
باسم الوزاره ان بلاده تعارض المواقع
والقواعد العسكريه الجديده للقوات
الامريكيه في الفلبين وبشان العلاقات مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي ذكر المتحدث الصيني ان
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد جوزيف
بوريل سيزور الصين في وقت لاحق من هذا
الشهر كما ستزور وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
الصين في خلال الايام المقبله وفقا
للخارجيه الصينيه
هذا واعلنت الوزاره التجاره الصينيه فتح
تحقيق بشان اجراءات تقليديه اتخذتها
تايوان فيما يتعلق بواردات المنتجات
الزراعيه والمعادن والكيماويات والمنسوجات
الصينيه
قد فرضت في وقت سابق قيودا تجاريا على هذه
الواردات الصينيه الى جانب
منتج والمعادن
المتحدثه بمكتب تايوان الصيني فقالت ان
الانشطه والاجراءات التي اتخذتها لا
تستهدف المواطنين في تايوان بل هي موجهه
للقوه الانفصاليه التي تدعو لاستقلال
الجزيره عن الوطن الام حسب قولها
كل الاجراءات الضروريه التي
ابتدتنا الوطنيه وسلامه اراضينا تستهدف
الانشطه الانفصاليه الداعيه الاستقلال
تايوان وكذلك تدخل القوه الخارجيه وهي
ليست موجهه باي حال من الاحوال ضد مواطنين
في تايوان ينبغي على المواطنين
التايوانيين الاعتراف بالضرر الجسيم الذي
تسببه استفزازات القوى الداعيه الاستقلال
التايوان للعلاقات عبر المضيق وفرص السلام
والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان على مواطنين في
تايوان الاعتراف بالمصالح والتمييز بين
الصواب والخطا والوقوف على الجانب الصحيح
من التاريخ